the morning panel
is devoted to the topic of energy usage
and dave lawrence will moderate
the panel
dave lawrence
is currently a director of stone energy
corporation
and before joining stone energy he
served as executive vice president of
exploration and commercial for shell
upstream americas and he was the
functional head of global exploration
for royal dutch shell from 2009 until
his retirement in
2013.
dave's also an earth scientist and he
received his doctorate
from the department of geology and
geophysics here at yale
1983
is that right dave 1983
or 84.
all right
uh
and we're quite happy to have him here
he's been a member of the external
advisory board for the yale climate
energy institute since its start in 2009
and i'm also pleased to announce that
dave has accepted our invitation to
serve as the new chair
of the yci advisory board so i'll let
dave introduce the rest of the panel
well
like neil
it's great to be with this group of
panelists who i think represents a range
of expert expertise and a diversity of
views
that i think will be greatly beneficial
to us i should say i'm very pleased to
take the
this
chairmanship role of the external
advisory board
for ycei
given the leadership and the direction
that it's had in the past and the
potential that i see
for it to have an impact
in not only areas of technology and
science but also in the regulatory space
and in the communication space and in
policy space
so it's a tremendous institution with a
lot of horsepower behind it
and uh sessions like this i think just
go a long way towards uh towards
demonstrating that
anil
i thought it was great to present us
with these shell scenarios
and the shell scenarios provide a
plausible and he really emphasized that
hope you took that away
plausible scenarios that lead to this
amount of energy use by sector this
amount of energy
use by different geopolitical realms and
therefore this amount of carbon
emissions and this is different
consequences
but i also think that you recognized
that
in those scenarios there wasn't very
much difference in the early years
and in the end they all resulted in a
significantly higher
amount of carbon in the atmosphere which
calls for
what are some disruptive technologies
that may come forward what will change
the rate
of market penetration
that we see
which is an area of great
interest to me
and i'm highly cognizant
of as we look at
different introductions of different
energy systems that there are things now
that we see that we didn't envision 10
years ago
and the quote that we tend to
overestimate change in three years and
underestimated in 10 in the energy space
i think is highly valid i like that
quote
in the comments but we
remember 10 years ago we were looking at
lng imports
in the us and now we're looking at lng
exports
the greatest change in the energy space
has come in natural gas which was a
dying industry and now look at in these
scenarios
how much it's taken its role in a
10-year span it was not like that 10
years ago
so what are the other technologies
what other policies
regulations things that could cause
these scenarios
as neil so eloquently presented to
change for us and i think that's why
it's great that
we've been able to bring forward this
panel
which is a panel of of again it's a
considerable expertise in a diversity of
fields in a diversity of geographies
and sectors so let me just introduce
the panel
to you
and i'll start with dan
dan is hill house professor dan este
who many of you have met is hill house
professor of environmental law and
policy
with appointments at both the yale law
school and the yale school of forestry
and environmental studies
he served the state of connecticut as
commissioner of the connecticut
department of energy and environmental
protection
dan is also the author and editor of
numerous uh publications highly
influential uh publications
and uh books including green to gold
how smart companies use environmental
strategies to innovate create value and
build so he'll bring i think a
tremendous perspective to our panel
uh professor zhang zhilang
is one of the leading economists in
china highly influential and one of the
most highly influential places on the
planet
working on climate
and energy policy
i'm hope i'm not underestimated i
underestimate in three years ten years
no
but he is
so he's worth listening to
and uh he's professor of economics and
executive director of the institute of
energy environment
and economy
at xinhua university in beijing
he's he's
authored
and led many studies important studies
and initiatives in china and was a lead
author in the last two ipcc climate
change projects so welcome
so it's a privilege to have you and
thank you for traveling this great
difference dan did not need to travel a
great distance
another great traveler
is uh is our next panelist is is karen
hussey is an associate professor
at the fenner school of environment and
society at australian national
university
and an expert on what is now being
called the water energy climate nexus
which also i thought that was great
karen that neil also raised that
important point in his introduction
she has a book coming out later this
year on that topic specifically so we'll
look forward to its publication
next
yes and buying that uh and it'll be from
cambridge university press and she's the
author of environment and sustainability
a policy handbook
so welcome karen thank you again for
traveling and she'll provide us also
some unique perspectives and luke
toneshell
is a highly respected senior vehicle
analyst for the national natural
resources defense council
he's based in
new york i note that today luke walked
here which is good well done luke
and where he studies ways to reduce the
environment environmental impacts of the
world's transportation system and again
you can think of that impact as you
looked at one of neil's charts
specifically on what will happen with
liquid uh transport fuels and what may
change that through time he also
served in the u.s navy so that brought
him a lot of perspective
on operations and propulsion as an
officer on a navy cruiser so welcome
luke
now in our panel everybody's been given
kind of strict instructions we'll see
how we do to stay within somewhere
between five and ten minutes
and and for their opening remarks
that'll give us a a useful perspective
and then we'll open the discussion uh to
the panelists for discussion
uh i'll ask some questions the panelists
you're welcome to ask each other uh
questions and most importantly we
welcome questions from the room so we're
going to leave ample time i think for a
good and open discussion
and
with that i think i'll turn over to you
dan to start off
thanks very much
speed up our movement from uh
presentations and opening comments to
conversation i'll stay seated and um
i do think the
conference that's been organized here
focuses um on a critical issue at a
critical moment which is the world is
changing very fast a lot of the
assumptions we had about what the world
would look like uh in the years ahead
have been radically shifted in the last
few years three four years
so the world going out to 2030 looks
very different today from what people
ask the same question would have said uh
at the turn of the century for app for
example 15 years ago
obviously the biggest piece of that in
some regards is the emergence of
shale gas tight oil and the
real revolution in the potential for
fossil fuels continuing to play a
central role in our energy future for a
much longer time than some people had
thought but i think at the same time we
see mounting pressure despite policy
failures particularly in washington and
to some degree internationally on the
issue of climate change and a growing
recognition that that pressure has to be
responded to and will be responded to
one way or another
and having just come from the experience
of working in a state government
i feel actually optimistic that the
united states is going to respond and i
say that despite the fact that
washington is clearly dithering
and has not been able to create a
strategy that really helps grapple with
this world of change that's emerged in
the energy arena but i am excited to see
um companies
taking these issues on frontally
neil's presentation on shell was a
fascinating example of a company
stepping up at the heart of this issue
in very creative ways a 40 shadow price
on carbon that's an extremely
interesting way for a company to
position itself
for
success in the years ahead and not
simply to wait to be buffeted by
regulatory change or other factors that
might overtake it
and i would tell you just as companies
are stepping up so too are a number of
states
and connecticut for example under
governor malloy created for the first
time ever a comprehensive energy
strategy uh for the longest time states
thought that energy was national policy
and it could be left to washington
nobody today thinks that that is a wise
place to leave your state and to leave
its citizens and frankly to leave your
businesses in a very competitive
marketplace so you see states stepping
up and i think in connecticut there were
some interesting signals about what the
policy framework of the future has to
look like
and how smart governments are aligning
incentives to be ready for the change
that's coming
some of it doesn't seem like rocket
science
but it is important for example
i was head of a department of energy and
environmental protection the acronym was
deep d-e-e-p
but i used to joke and the governor
actually insisted that we spell deep
with three e's
energy the environment and the economy
as an integrated set of issues that had
to be understood as a package that
needed to be thought through on an
integrated basis
and i think in the energy arena more
broadly we're seeing a very significant
change from a 20th century approach to
energy to a new 21st century approach
and to caricature slightly but not too
greatly the 20th century approach had a
bunch of smart folks
some of them at least at the department
of energy in washington uh from a u.s
perspective this is trying to pick
winners
winning technologies winning industries
winning companies and frankly the track
record is not that bad but not that good
and we've spent 20 billion dollars as a
nation
invested in one big
alternative fuel for the future and
probably everyone in this room knows
it is
corn based ethanol
and having just said the 20th century
model is to have the government pick
winners and it's not a very good thing
i'm willing to pick a loser and it's
corn-based ethanol
and i just think the the energy transfer
takes three units of fossil fuel input
to get four units of corn based ethanol
out uh the food fuel trade-off it
creates the stress on water systems and
i hope we'll get some more on in a few
minutes makes this a loser for sure so
the government picks winners not on the
basis of market logic or sustainability
or ability to meet the needs of society
over time but on short-term political
logic that almost always is not a good
basis for driving major investments so i
think you see in connecticut a new
approach emerging
not the government picking winners not
subsidy but a finance approach creating
a platform for entrepreneurial activity
and relying on our limited government
resources or ratepayer funds to leverage
private capital why is that important
first of all the government doesn't have
enough money to do all the projects to
invest in all the infrastructure and to
support all of the efforts that need to
be undertaken second and more
importantly
relying on the private sector provides a
discipline that governments lack in
where the money gets spent so it
transforms completely how you deploy
your limited resources and i think
connecticut's already seen a boom in its
clean energy flow of capital into
efficiency into renewables into fuel
switching towards cheaper cleaner and
more reliable natural gas and out of
coal and oil in a way that is quite
fascinating and it's not by accident it
does require kind of a new policy
framework so you see in connecticut not
solar wrecks and wind wrecks which is
the old 20th century model but a zero
emissions renewable energy credit it
requires all technologies to compete
against each other so you're harnessing
market forces competition in particular
to drive down the cost of renewable
energy and i promise you the single most
important factor for whether we get to a
clean energy future is the pace at which
the cost of clean energy renewable power
in any of its forms comes toward
approaches and finally surpasses the
price of fossil fuel alternatives
particularly the generation of power
that's the key to success in this
marketplace and structuring policy
incentives to get there is what's
absolutely critical
now beyond that connecticut used
a set of reverse auctions to drive down
costs it used power purchase agreements
as opposed to a renewable portfolio
standard to again lower costs and it
turns out that some of the prevailing
wisdom of the 20th century just didn't
work
a renewable portfolio standard which
connecticut's had for 15 years
ratcheting up the percent of power
that's meant to be renewable uh up to 20
by 2020 has produced zero grid scale
renewable energy projects in 15 years
zero no wind projects no solar arrays
because it's a target it's a timetable
it's a command and control approach it
doesn't work
what did work was saying the state would
like to purchase renewable energy all of
you who have projects tell us what you
can do and at what cost and we will give
you if you are the low bidder
a 15 or 20 year contract to sell power
in the state of connecticut
so the number of people that were able
to get projects financed when they had a
renewable energy portfolio standard to
0.2 in connecticut zero once you have a
contract in hand you can go to a bank
and borrow a hundred million dollars to
build a wind farm very different
approach so we are seeing new tools that
work a more integrated strategy
a focus on a portfolio approach to the
future there will be a fossil fuel
dimension to it for some many years to
come but we are at the same time ramping
up renewable energy ramping up
efficiency and by the way after years of
very slow ramp we saw a ten-fold
increase in the pace at which renewable
energy is being deployed at the
household scale and the grid scale in
the last couple of years as opposed to
the years prior to that
we also are seeing a need for
integration not only of strategy but of
states
it doesn't work for each state to do
this on their own we're waiting for a
national a national program that's not
coming so you now have the new england
states banding together investing again
in a portfolio approach that has
transport uh trans uh the transmission
lines being built has gas pipelines
being built is really designed to ensure
that the state is going to be able to
benefit from the markets that are out
there and the prices that are prevailing
in some places and i just point out
natural gas because of the growing
supply uh is selling in new york today
at prices under the benchmark henry hub
and the gulf the price in new england
double that this is a bottleneck problem
and an infrastructure issue so the new
england states are working together to
overcome that my bottom line and really
what i offer as the key to the 21st
century strategy is the need to think
about innovation more broadly than it
was in the 20th century a lot of push
was put on technology development
remains important we want to continue to
see venture capital not so much
government money but venture capital
going into breakthrough technologies but
we need innovation as well in finance
which is why connecticut set up a green
bank to do this kind of creative
financing we need creative policies new
frameworks of incentives we need
innovation in how we engage the public
in the marketing of clean energy so it's
innovation broadly in the entire
ecosystem of energy that is what's going
to get us to a transformed future and is
allow us to manage these fast changing
issues that we see around us
thank you
dan um
i think we will uh have a lot of
good discussion on winners versus losers
um economics trumping
others this portfolio approach is an
essential approach and it's great to see
the success that
it's helped deliver uh in in connecticut
and i think the uh
clearly as we talk and look towards
china things like looking at
infrastructure
and the challenges of distributing to
different markets will become a common
theme we will now turn towards china
which
is in many ways
you'll tell us if i'm wrong here the
opposite
of the u.s
with a strong central planning
for an energy system
which in so doing is adding energy
capacity
more rapidly than any other country
in the world
professor zhang perhaps you can
tell us something about what we should
expect to see happening in the world of
energy in the next 10 to 15 years in
china and maybe how that compares a
little bit to the rest of the world
thank you thank you very much
it's really a great pleasure to be here
to to join the very interesting
discussion and also give me an
opportunity to share with you some of
all perspectives so about chinese energy
and co2 emission
and
just the the moderator i mentioned so
i'm very important i know what is
meaning because china is the largest
entity consuming lesion so in the world
and last year the total primary energy
consumption reached
3.7 billion tons of co-equivalent
and if you look at the the mix the
analyst polymix so we will see
still 66 66 percent
from coal
and and also the oil uh accounted for
approximately
19 percent and natural gas
5.8
non-fossil fuels that means nuclear plus
renewables altogether so uh it's about
uh
nine point uh
nine point eight percent so you can see
cold steel
coal and fossil fuels and potential coal
still dominated or any supply mix
and also for the power and region so i
channel uh the portland region capacity
also reached about uh 12 uh 12 000
gigabytes last year and approximately
65 from coal and the natural gas is
about uh six is about three point five
percent and uh and and also at the
renewable recently for the past two days
for the past two decades uh within is a
very fast uh growth but already know the
member is still the share is still very
low for example
the china is the largest installation
nation of window turbines but the
contribution for portland region is only
5.2
and the solar energy and the nuclear is
about 1.2 percent and but for the
renewable the hydra so for the pollen
region is the share is very high it's
approximately 21
so this is the the situation of the
anti-consumption and the pollination so
from this
supply mix we can see
it also lead to
the china become also the largest carbon
oxide emitter in the world so and
right now we know and
approximately one quarter of the total
carbon dioxide emission in the world
from china comes from china and and more
importantly approximately 60 of
increased carbon dioxide emission from
china so and
and this is why it happens so i think
it's very much related to three major
drivers for trans energy consumption and
also co2 emission so why is the
industrialization the second is the
urbanization the third is the
modernization so because in the near
future these three major drivers still
increase so we can expect the china's
co2 emission and energy consumption will
keep going up but i but we believe the
growth rate will be
going down so according to our recent
projection
uh this based on a t1 mit i don't
research product so by the year uh 2020
so china uh china's total energy
consumption could be uh approximately uh
55 billion teams of
kinds of co-equivalent 5 billion and by
the year 2020 it could be 6
billion
6 billion things of kodi equivalent so
and and also if really to
in addition to address the co2 emissions
china how to also address the very
serious domestic environmental
challenges so i'm very happy i'm very
and also i'm very thankful
for the imitation for me to keep to come
here because
because i sit here i get rid of the
smokes so invading
so you know for this couple of weeks for
this week beijing the smoke is very
serious the pollution index is is
soaring very high so i should very much
thank uh mike invited me to get here so
and also to address uh not only the co2
emissions also the
the air quality issues the china showed
for a short uh subs should take a
substantial efforts uh for the promotes
the renewable energy and the non-fossil
fuels so according to all projection so
by the year 2020 the non-fossil fuel
contribution
could be 15
and by the year 20 uh by the year 2030
it could be
20 uh
25
and as after year 2030
the increased energy consumption could
be
supplied by the non-fossil fuels the
nuclear and the renewables such that
china's co2 emission could peak so at
the year
2030.
so this is the the pictures but you see
that the big challenge is
the chinese economy population is very
harsh so to address this uh how to say
uh the challenges will take substantial
efforts and also we need of course we
also need a policy yes we are very
centralized planning nation so china's
policy approach is largely top down so
for the past
10 years
and for example so we have a energy
planning exercise from the central
government to the county government the
lowest government so in china and
the very
the critical work of the the energy
planning is is to set legally spending
targets for the energy co2 emission and
the renewables so and these these so
these targets can can horsey give a
signal a message for mobilizing the
research resources to water errors so i
think it's very important in addition to
the the national
legally
in addition to the targets and also
there is also approach is very unique in
china this aggregating the national uh
targets into provinces so make the the
provincial governors and uh and even the
large the leaders of the industry be
responsible for energy conservation and
co2 and mitigation so and there is a
agreement between the the government and
the major and the consumers and the co2
majors so
in china
so this is a so-called commander control
approach commander control approach but
we also re and also recently china
learned to use market-based policy
instruments so including the tax
tax policy and also uh the bonus and the
energy contribution in subsidies
investment and renewable energy
renewable electricity feeding in
terrorists and the electricity surcharge
for renewable development and also
recently so uh so
for the past uh two for the past three
years china
started
cap and treat emissions carbon the
carbon dioxide emission cap and treat
palace so in the five
cities and province including beijing
and right now according to just after
you know the third plan the third
party's plenum has already set many
directions for further reform tennis
economy and also uh come up with very
little specific directions for reform
china's energy and climate policy so
according to the the the new uh reform
initiative china will build a national
uh
cap and trade scheme by the year 2020 so
and just yesterday so i received a call
from the national development reform
commission would like me to to join so a
meeting next week talking about the
sighting of the national targets and how
to this upgrading the national targets
to the provinces and what's kit what
kind of key approves to allocate the the
co2 emission into under presses so and
that means this isn't that means this is
a series because that the central
government have a road map to the
central grammy uh the central government
the central government that or the lead
council request the national uh
development information to formulate a
road map so and
this the major work should be finished
by the year by the end of this year so i
think this is
maybe the
let's call it top-down approach so based
on
based on chinese political system but i
think that this is the the the story for
the recently but uh but this is the part
of the story was recently but also there
is a new i think a momentum and because
this is the social awareness about iran
and pollution and the climate change in
china has released as muslim people and
i think
that because of the risk of a social
awareness make it possible for more
easier to implement
china's this climate energy policy
it's a largely big slightly due to the
smokes
okay thank you very much
uh
you know i'm struck again by
uh a couple of things
one is that with the central planning
approach the dimensions of change uh
that have been achieved in in china in
all
areas
of energy use and dwarfs
other economies and and other host
nations so it's it's quite a remarkable
achievement i'm also struck and those
some of us listened to dan's talk last
night on other talk on communications
and
how you can take different numbers and
and lots of very interesting facts
coming out one of which is you know the
tremendous growth in renewables and in
solar and others which it is also uh
quite spectacular
at the same time
the growth in coal and the dilemma that
that creates to meet the the societal
needs for energy in china and how do we
balance those so we'll talk about that
but think of that as we kind of as you
think about rates of market penetration
and what it would really take
uh to have a greater percentage for
example of renewables it's just an it's
an important aspect so now
let's uh continue
in places across
the globe globe thanks karen that's
wonderful we're going to talk about the
largest uses of energy
in transportation and electric uh power
and karen hassan entered we'll talk
about an energy future
that has been talked about for many
years in electrification and its impact
the electrification i think of literally
everything what kind of impact would
that have
i'm not sure you're going to address
that
directly but is the electric power
sector really ready
for massive electrification and how will
this likely to affect national energy
grids and what will be the
impact on this kind of stress nexus that
we talk about with water and energy use
and distribution so karen i'll turn it
over to you thank you very much um
apologies for not sitting down i'm much
better on my feet
um i'm very grateful to be here so thank
you very much to the yale climate and
energy institute um i'm grateful to be
here for different reasons to zhang he
was very pleased to get away from the
the smoke and the smog
i was very grateful to see some real
rain
uh so thank you very much uh i could do
without the cold though uh that's a
that's a struggle today
and
so as dave said i was i was asked to
focus particularly on the electricity
sector and today i want to focus on uh
three emerging or continuing
developments uh that affect very
strongly our capacity to generate
electricity
and decisions around where and how we
can generate electricity uh so i want to
discuss those three issues and and then
conclude uh very briefly with uh what i
think the consequences might be
uh for electricity production moving
forward particularly the actors involved
in the business models that will
underpin
electricity in the future
so the first issue which is very close
to my heart
and which has been touched on already is
the electricity sector's demand for
water
um and it's my contention and others um
that this nexus between electricity uh
or energy generally but electricity
particularly and water is going to place
increasing constraints
on
where and how
electricity can be generated
uh to give you just a a very quick uh
sort of precis on that link between
energy and water just
consider for a moment that to produce
one liter of petroleum oil
requires anything from seven to fifteen
liters of water
to produce natural gas
you're looking at 20 to 50 liters of
water per barrel of equivalent oil
and in terms of hydraulic fracking which
is
a
major concern in australia and and i
know in the united states as well
you can be looking at anything from
eight to thirty million liters of water
uh produced uh per well
per well
okay
so the relationship between energy and
water is very very strong
and we're only really starting to come
to grips with that uh now
the risks posed by water to electricity
in particular are four-fold
the first is is very obvious it's water
availability okay do we have enough
water
to be able to cool our power plants to
be able to extract those gas and oil
reserves
the second is an increasing ambient
water temperature it's very difficult to
use water as a coolant if it's already
warm
right and we have found this to be a
real problem in australia the third is
increasing variability
which exists anyway but is going to be
exacerbated by climate change
um and the fourth is not mentioned uh
very much at all in any of the
literature um and that is the the other
impacts of climate change that are going
to have an effect on critical
infrastructure so we're seeing
increasing cyclones increasing flooding
uh and even increasing bushfires in
australia and elsewhere in the world
which is affecting your you know your
your your assets right we're seeing uh
plants destroyed or
at least affected by floods bushfires
cyclones and the like and so this is
expensive which will ultimately be
passed on to the consumer
so it's a very real problem and it has
very real impacts almost everywhere in
the world
we saw
a very sort of perverse outcome from the
delay in the monsoonal
rains in india a couple of years ago
which meant that there was an increased
demand for groundwater pumping in the
absence of the monsoonal rains which of
course put enormous pressure on the
electricity sector in india we've seen
in the united states in australia in
france in germany
nuclear power plants and other power
plants have to shut down
and interrupt energy supply because of
an absence of available water resources
okay so it's a real problem and it's
very much alive
once you throw land into the mix
and you bring in the consequences for
agricultural production and food prices
uh all bets are off and in 2009 we saw
what happens when you have a spike in
staple food products
um
so
the
um oh i should also point out that that
there is no particular technology that
is immune from this problem right the
most obvious is hydroelectricity right
but that's that's it doesn't stop there
any kind of thermal power generation is
vulnerable to scarce water resources uh
anything that uses water as a coolant is
vulnerable uh to ambient uh increase in
ambient water temperature okay fracking
is is another one biofuels you know it's
off the chart in terms of water risk
water resource consumption so i think
understanding the nexus and starting to
act on it is going to have three
consequences the first is we're already
seeing this is we're going to see
changes in standards around energy
efficiency around where you can site
electricity generation
plants
there's going to be a whole suite of
water triggers within the regulatory
arrangements to ensure that sensible
decisions are made
we're also going to see things like
cogeneration where instead of using
fresh water resources we might see
desalination used and we'll just cop the
uh the energy cost of that
we may well see more efficient and
interconnected
electricity markets to promote greater
flexibility
right we have a national electricity
market in australia so when we can't use
our hydro facility down south we can buy
buy energy from up north all right now
that's great for us but it's my
contention that we might actually see
greater more flexible competitive
integrated energy markets and
electricity markets in places like
southeast asia okay where this issue
starts to get more and more alive as
they develop further
the most exciting aspect of this to me
and i share um dan's enthusiasm about
renewable energy technology is that it
just makes that argument to use
renewable energy technologies that much
more compelling okay now the knock-on
consequences of that which i get very
pink about is the potential for uh
distributed energy storage technologies
to be
a support mechanism to enable that
renewable energy penetration and i don't
want to trample all over this
afternoon's panel
but suffice it to say that in australia
in the united states in parts of europe
there have been some amazing initiatives
just in the last three years around
pilot projects for distributed energy
storage
and what that is
precipitating in australia at any rate
is new business models
so uh just this week in australia the
macquarie bank group
applied to be an energy
retailer
right it applied for electricity retail
license
right
so
it's my contention that if we see more
renewables we see we see more
distributed energy storage we're going
to see different actors different people
will be producing energy
and
that's going to require a whole shift in
our regulatory framework
so that was the second issue i forgot to
start with that
the third issue is the persistent price
differentials that exist between regions
for electricity okay
in europe and in japan they pay two
three at the moment three times as much
for their electricity uh the world
energy outlook report from last year
suggests that by 2035 they'll still be
paying twice as much for electricity as
the united states that has profound
implications for energy intensive uh
production particularly energy intensive
trade exposed
commodities
so where i think this brings us to if we
take the water energy and more recently
the land nexus
combined with the penetration of
renewable energy technologies and what i
think that means for energy storage
plus
the potential for
a greater incentive for integrated
grids more competitive more flexible
integrated electricity grids in places
where they're not currently integrated i
think we see a number of consequences um
and and like neil please don't make
investment decisions based on this
um i think we're going to see
fundamental reform and eventually
transformation of the electricity sector
in a number of ways we're going to see
reform of pricing particularly to
account for the externalities of water
impacts
we're going to see new business models
new actors
but new risks that come with those new
business models and i'll go into that in
detail in in question time if you like i
think we're going to see
two weird things happen yeah and as a
political scientist of course i'm you
know i'm focused on the role of the
state and who's doing what i think we're
going to see two things happen one is
we're going to have increasingly
decentralized distributed electricity
sectors
so we've got more actors we've got
really innovative different business
models
and we've got distributed energy
technologies
renewable plus storage but i think we're
at the international level we're going
to see much more integration and
cooperation and collaboration to allow
for those
very real climate risks and water risks
simply to bring about greater energy
security
so i think it's an exciting space
and i'm happy to explore any or all of
that in questions
thank you very much uh
karen and again appreciation for travels
to to to share this with us
you know clearly reminding us of the
importance of water
in the energy space and in many places
without water there is no energy so i
think just extraordinarily uh
important i'm really interested in the
questions as we talk about the the risks
of these new business models so one of
you remember that uh
question and i also thought it brought
up in addition uh to the
very fascinating new methods of
distribution
and so forth of electricity this need
for capital and the importance of
capital becoming involved in this and
and how that will influence uh the
markets that we have so thank you again
for a very thorough uh review in a short
time
let's move on to our last
but not least by any means a presenter
uh luke
transportation right now is is one uh
part of the energy sector where a single
source currently oil uh dominates and
and again neil showed that in his
presentation and really right for right
now has a pretty strong lock not a not a
lock type but a strong lock on usage in
the u.s for example i think and you'll
correct me if this is off is about 95 of
the transportation
comes from oil so can you tell us how
you view this changing through time and
what some of the drivers might be that
would cause that to change
thanks
great
thank you david um
it's a great pleasure for me to be here
it's an honor to be on this panel and
and um thanks very much
to the climate and energy institute for
the invitation
you know it was uh it was it was nice to
learn of our connection uh my connection
with the
background that neil has and
in the sense that we both served in the
navy
one of the things that you learn very
quickly as an officer standing uh watch
on the bridge is that when you come
across a a tanker
or a cargo ship out on the ocean that
ship is not going to move its course for
you
you're going to move for it um
and
uh
you know the
the
uh
you know the the cruiser that i was on
typical navy ships were manned up to
to go to volatile areas and to uh change
our our way of doing business very
quickly
um
you know we may have on the ship i was
on we had 600 crew members including the
officers
a tanker or a
cargo ship might have 15 or a handful
um
and so
i bring that up from the standpoint that
the us obviously
is a
in a sense of the energy
world
we're kind of a tanker
you know we're a huge consumer
china is obviously coming up
and passing us in ways but um we can't
keep the course steady and expect
everyone to move around us we need to to
to
move more like a navy ship and take
advantage of the innovation that we can
put forth and help that guide sort of
the direction uh that we take going
forward
i'm going to focus on
a united states perspective
mainly because that's the area that i
work in
but because of the opportunity for us to
take really a strong leadership role
as dave mentioned you can't you can't
talk about um
can't talk about the transportation
sector and uh and not talk about oil
you know because it is basically the
source of fuel for the transportation
sector in the u.s the transportation
sector is responsible for about 70
percent of the
consumption of oil
and if you look at oil as a primary
energy source it is the number one
source of greenhouse gas emissions in
the united states
from a climate perspective why do we why
do i work on vehicles and fuels in the
transportation sector where the
transportation sector is it contributes
about a third of our pollution uh
climate pollution uh nationally and
about
80 percent of that transportation sector
emissions comes from vehicles on our
roads so
understandably they need to be a an area
of focus as well
i wanted to quickly sort of paint the
situation of where we are
and some ideas some points ahead for
what what the future may look like
according to some forecasts and so the
blue box here represents
uh
kind of what our expected emissions for
the u.s transportation sector uh from a
co2 perspective
if you're
just thinking about what the policies
are that are in place right now and if
you look in a 2030 time frame
the red represents kind of the
trajectory that we were on the red
dotted line and you can see that we were
headed towards higher missions
and
the green
represents really a trajectory that we
need to be on
to meet an 80 reduction in greenhouse
gas emissions by 2050 relative to 2005.
so
the fact that we're below the red
means that uh we've made some progress
and we should we should recognize that
and think about what it is that's gotten
us there
but of course the fact that we're still
above the green means that we have quite
a bit of work to do
so
when we talk about you know sort of how
we reduce emissions and
oil use in the transportation sector we
focus on traditionally it's a solution
uh stool built on three legs those three
legs are basically how much fuel our
vehicles use per mile that they drive or
their efficiency
it's how much do we actually have a
demand for driving or are vehicle miles
traveled and third it's what we put in
what's the carbon intensity of the fuel
that we put in so i'm going to touch on
each of those those very briefly
here we have in the first area
efficiency we have a great story
actually here in the u.s and this has
been a large chunk of where our emission
reductions have come from this chart
here is showing the progressions from
2007 out to the present monthly uh tabs
on it of what
the
new vehicles fuel efficiency of the new
vehicle fleet is produced in the united
states
now this just shows the upward trend
over the last you know since 2007 over
the last seven years or so
but if you were to take this trend back
what you would see is that actually it
was just this long flat period for for
for decades where we didn't increase
fuel efficiency standards at all
and actually our fuel efficiency as a
new vehicle fuel efficiency was uh
was going down because of the shift
towards higher
fuel use in
in the basically the shift towards suvs
so this has been a huge policy success
it's been really a landmark program of
the obama administration to put these
standards in place
set over two stages in 2010 and 2012 but
i wanna to dance point about the role of
the states this was uh leading into this
was that a lot of states were using
authority under the clean air act to set
greenhouse gas emission standards for
vehicles leading in
to this federal process and was really a
helpful push in that connecticut being
one of the states that had adopted
california's program and so the states
as a laboratory
and as a push to get federal policy is
continues to be very important
this isn't happening just in cars and
light trucks but it's also in happening
in the heavy duty sector and
right now the administration is looking
at the second phase of the of fuel
efficiency standards for heavy duty
trucks and working on that right now
and so that's going to be
a major factor
one of the main pieces that's going to
help us close that gap between where we
are and where we need to be even in a
2030 uh time frame
the vmt picture
uh for decades vmt or vehicle miles
traveled has been on
a a very rapid rise in the united states
but what we've seen recently
is that actually
questions being asked by a lot of
researchers is whether or not we've sort
of peaked
are we on the way down actually and
once one uh some folks are thinking that
on a per capita basis people are going
to actually
not drive more but we actually may
start be continue to see a decline in
per capita and with that decline in per
capita we could see a leveling off of
emissions
in total demand for driving and you know
this is due to a lot of different
factors economics demographics
you know no longer is it that everyone
has to drive somewhere to meet up when
when everyone now has a smartphone in
their pocket that can do
you know can talk to each other via the
web
so
you know um a lot of factors are are at
play here but
it's something that's become real uh a
real
thing to study in terms of where the
even the energy information
administration is now focused on this
and that what they've looked at is that
even in one of their low vmt scenarios
this could reduce uh petroleum
consumption in in the transportation
sector by like 18 percent
just this reduced demand and driving
where historically this was just
something that was up going up up up and
up
now those are pretty positive stories
let's talk about the fuel sector now
this is a less positive story or let's
say it's an opportunity an area for a
lot of opportunity
so this this graphic here is emphasizing
the fact that
we have uh
as as we continue to have demand for
petroleum we're going after harder to
reach sources and we're going after
higher carbon intensity sources so in
this case it's the tar sands from canada
if that becomes a large part portion of
the fuel mix
that doesn't that that pushes our um
transportation sector carbon emissions
in the upward direction so basically
we're counteracting all these things
that we're doing with vehicle efficiency
or a shift towards electric vehicles
we're counteracting that if we move
towards more high carbon intensive fuels
this graphic is focused on highlighting
kind of the regional impact here in in
connecticut and surrounding states we
get about half of our
fuel supply from pipeline that comes
from the gulf and refineries from those
gulf refineries
and also we have some refineries in our
region
so if tar sands gets to the gulf we'll
get part of that it's also as more tar
sands moves by rail or if pipelines get
reversed that's being talked about in
canada then we're going to get more tar
sands into our regional refineries
that's going to
increase the carbon uh footprint of the
fuel supply that we use just to give a
sense of what that means
we have this
really landmark cap and trade system or
not cap and trade but a relatively cap
and trade system on our electricity
sector in the region called the regional
greenhouse gas initiative
over five years that's projected to
reduce emissions by on the order of 11
million metric tons
if we hit what could be projected to be
18 of our fuel supply from tar sands in
this region
in one year that'll increase our
emissions profile by 10 million metric
tons it would offset
essentially what we're trying to achieve
in five years
within the electric electricity sector
so what they're
one of the policy levers that could be
that could really help us drive forth
towards innovation in the clean vehicle
the clean fuel sector
is something
called a clean fuel standard and what
that does is it has a two-fold effect it
basically says the carbon intensity of
the fuel supply needs to go down over
time and it sets a standard a
performance standard just like fuel
efficiency standards for cars this would
be a
a carbon intensity standard for fuel
if you set a trajectory of where that
has to go down that shifts investment
away from
things like carbon intensive fuels and
towards things like
electricity for vehicles
potentially non-feud fuel biomass for
biofuels
uh
hydrogen powered uh electric bus here
those examples are things where the
you're creating a market so again you're
not dependent on a lot of uh
federal or i mean public money but
you're creating a market that spurs that
innovation and i'm happy to talk more
about that as we get to
the q a
finally we have examples of where we
really need to be to meet our long-term
climate and energy goals in the
transportation sector we need to
shift to electric drive vehicles
the reason for that is that electric
drives gives you the best efficiency
but also the fuel there in this case
plug in electric vehicles using
electricity from the grid it's the one
fuel that's actually getting cleaner
over time
we're not going to meet our our
long-term climate goals unless we clean
up both the electricity sector and the
transportation sector so let's do that
hand in hand let's get the vehicles out
there that can actually use the cleaner
electricity
as we move in that direction these are
vehicles that are cleaner today but
there will only get cleaner over time
and you can't say that for any of the
fossil fuel uh directly you know liquid
fuels and i you know this slide also
points to a lot of the
things that karen started to raise and
that there's a there's a great
interaction
between electric vehicles and where the
electric power grid is going and
basically when you talk about electric
storage
technology every one of these cars has
the potential to be an electric storage
technology or to be a mobile
on-demand load that really helps manage
the intermittency of renewable power so
hopefully that's a good lead in for the
discussion thanks very much for your
attention and look forward to
you may have received an questions card
with a pencil
uh from one of the students that's not
for your lunch order
uh those are for questions so we'll be
collecting them we will have the likes
for questions if you want to voice your
questions but we will be collecting the
cards
questions
yeah and again thanks very much and
thanks luke for uh showing what i think
are some real opportunities but also the
balanced view on some of the challenges
that are faced in the transportation
sector
i'll open it up in a in just a second
for maybe the panelists want to ask each
other
uh some some questions but if if you
don't mind
uh i'd like to
just take the bully pulpit here and and
just have the chance for maybe the the
the first one
and i wondered
in the audience
as you
listened to
neil's presentation on these different
scenarios
whether that created any kind of tension
or stress within you
as you looked at did you think those
scenarios were real or
what was the context of those in the
fact basin and again what's the kind of
the belief system that you bring to uh
to looking at that data
because one of the things that they
showed all showed
was an increase to meet the energy
demands and as i think you highlighted
in china for the continued use of of
fossil fuels
so i wanted to ask the panelists just in
view of that discomfort because that
takes you to a certain point with co2
where do you see as the greatest
opportunities for true
disruptive technologies policies
innovations and breakthroughs
that could change
some of those scenarios
that neil uh presented and where would
you focus
where would you focus your efforts now
and i'll open that to the panel
i'm happy to start i
you know i think that
working at nrdc obviously we're an
environmental advocacy organization um
you can't go to work every day and think
that
we're not going to be able to solve the
the very challenging problems that we
have in front of us with regard to
meeting our climate targets
so i guess what first thing that struck
me was you know and that was
the tie into my my ship analogy was that
i you know we we can't be satisfied with
that as as the direction we have to look
towards this innovation
and
um
and so i think
you know and this is uh
consistent with some of dan's points
earlier we need to set up a framework
especially in our fuel system
that
um
it's not you know the clean fuel
standard doesn't pick a fuel
it opens up a a market for anybody that
comes along and wants to compete in that
market and where you know this is a a
policy that's actually in place in
california today they call it a low
carbon fuel standard
and um
you know what's interesting in that is
that the regulated entities are the
refiners and they they have to provide
fuel that is lower lowering its carbon
intensity over time
but one of the main players in that
market right now are the electric
utilities because they're creating
credits
because they're selling electricity to
uh power vehicles they create credits
that could be available to the market
for the refiners to buy
and that's creating um
basically it's it's moving towards
providing more and final financial
incentives for the utilities to to
encourage more people to get into
electric vehicles
and you have this self-fulfilling sort
of turnaround where you can use that as
a way of accelerating this technology
and the last slide i had up there i
titled it clean energy
it's our future today
with this plug-in electric vehicle
because it is a technology that is here
today and the issue that we really have
is how do we accelerate it
and you know that driving electric
vehicles are equivalent to driving on
national average
electricity prices is equivalent to
driving
uh on the equivalent of a buck a gallon
gasoline who doesn't want that that's a
real payback and so the question is how
do you get over that upfront cost of the
vehicle
and and things like this nexus with the
electricity sector can can help deal
with some of those things
i
was impressed by the array of ideas that
our panel put forward and um so dave i
hate to pick on you but i actually think
the question you asked is the question
people asked in the 20th century and we
tried to guess answers and i actually
reject the question um smart
smart people smart people shouldn't be
guessing we should be trying these out
and doing more of what works and we need
to be more empirical and we need
innovation in every arena and we need to
see um what's going to break through
who's going to bring costs down so that
we can compete with a status quo and
eventually displace it and you know i
think the the great joy is that the the
smart people in serena including you
yourself don't have to guess um because
we're seeing so much breaking through on
the ground and that's what i'm excited
about i'm excited to see so many
companies out there trying out new
approaches and again not just products
but services and efficiency improvements
and a whole wide array of things so i
think um the key is and i think it's
again a theme that emerged here is
trying to ensure that we have the
incentive structure in place that will
facilitate that boom in idea testing in
the marketplace and i do think it's
around financing um and you know we we
had luke say you want to make sure that
the choice of the electric vehicle which
could be a superior option doesn't come
at a huge premium to your next best
alternative so that's why i think the
the innovation in finance is
particularly important not just in terms
of vehicles but in terms of getting
every building improved to the greatest
extent possible if it can be done with a
no upfront cost package of financing and
a
positive cash flow loan you're going to
get a lot more people to step up and do
it so i i want to have a broad view of
where breakthroughs are going to come
and try lots of things out and do more
of what works and pull back on the
things that don't
in relation
yeah you're probably going to reject my
answer um
so you know i have i have sort of two
cautionary remarks about
the about scenarios where is neil
where is he
no is he gone he's gone is he i can say
what i like
so
i think they're dangerous um
oh he's coming back better not um
scenarios are enormously useful for
providing alternative visions
but my my fear with um with all
scenarios but but even when i look at
the the shell scenarios um
is twofold
one is we never get it right
right so they provide these alternative
visions but if you go back to what we
were talking about 30 years or 40 years
ago and what they projected was going to
happen
it didn't
right
it's always off course
sometimes wildly
and that in itself is okay right we
still need somebody laying out some well
thought out scenario analysis and and
shell does a very good job as does the
international energy agency et cetera et
cetera
but
where i get really concerned is that if
you look at either of those scenarios
they're both really depressing
and i think it's often used
by those that want to maintain the
status quo as an opportunity to say
well look you know it we shouldn't
really make this move because clearly
all the indicators are suggesting that
we would be um
screaming in the wind all right there's
another expression but i'm not allowed
to use that um
so
so i think when we look at the scenario
analyses we need to just say
very useful
but let not let that not cloud the
vision and innovation that can come
you know if we say all bets are off
let's look at what the indicators are
saying and as all of us i think have
have said there's tremendous optimism
let's focus on the optimism
thanks karen
okay so i actually
has also do a lot of scenario work so as
a professor i often told my students
please do your best to watch rubbish in
and rubbish out so that means that the
assumptions i know in addition to the
methodology the modeling framework
itself the assumptions and also the
understanding of the issues so it's very
important so and in the context of
channel
for uh to the channel and the scenario
one still to imagine mission scenario
the challenge is very hard so and
so i think for the for the trainers of
the the enemy's consumption and the the
suit immediate future a lot of
uncertainties so we should be carefully
uh
a lot of uncertainties we so far we have
not well uh
maybe it's beyond all capacity to to uh
to deal with this
so why is the chinese economic for china
for the chinese energy's future i think
very much
a big the largest uh uncertainty is the
economic growth
so according to
going to all estimation
so uh 0.1 of
increase uh in the
economic growth in the in the annual
economic growth would lead to uh 1
billion tons of co2 emission added per
year 2030. so this is very big so the
economic growth rate changes a little
bit it will lead to a very significant
co2 emission and energy consumption so
in the context channel so uh in the past
so the past 22 decades china pursued a
higher economic growth rate the the
economic growth visit the economic
growth rate on average is over ten
percent so the economic growth issue is
very high but also the economic cost is
very high so that's why we have uh
smokes so it's big very big problem to
threaten the life of the people so and
in the future so now the government
would like to see to have a shift and
also from the shift would like to pursue
a lock a relative low but sustainable
growth rate
this is at the central level central
government levels idea but usually you
know so the local garments maybe they
have sometimes they have a different
idea so their major motivation is the
atomic growth rate homicides
really happens so i think it's a very
big uh uncertainty so another
uncertainty in contact with china is
related to the the code
so and
china is a it's a big code the code
resource is abounded so there is a lot
of discussion so in china if we can use
the code in a clean way
and the channels they have a
lot of
big research program research and
development program
on the
polygon racing and ccis et cetera so it
also as this kind of research and
technology
yeah so it is also there is a
uncertainty so if if we get a
breakthrough it makes
we can have a come up with
when we have a reliable
and environmentally uh
friendly
way of to use the code it will be yeah
it's it's also changed the chinese
energy supply mix so
right now we are in china we also very
much would like to see when should the
pitch that can the
the the king co-consumption peak could
occur in china because most of the
environmental problem and also to
emission problem problem also with the
code
so now we are there is a community in
china to push the code consumption we
peak as as far as as soon as possible
but other people also maybe scientists
maybe also their technology so i think
another uncertainty is about associated
with china's grid grid so if really the
the smart grid the technology be
available and be get through recently
really soon so this make the the solar
pivot technology be really
readily uh used in the cities so and
so i mean i think this is that of course
the policies and of course if the really
determination of the government if they
can really push so these policies they
have some ideas with some directions
okay
thank you thank you very much let me
open it up to the panel since you've
done all the work here to ask
whatever questions that you may have for
each other
fuel performance standard and the aim
here is to assess carbon intensity
to what extent could that fuel standard
also assess
land switching and water intensity as
well because if you focus on carbon
alone we're just going to create other
issues
one of the things that the
california system has been
looking at and we feel needs to go
further is
a more general sustainability metric
related to the the fuel so um and that's
where you would start to roll in
uh water usage um
and i think even
you can get into
human rights issues you can you can go
quite a ways there fortunately there are
standards now
like the renewable
rsb the renewable
sustainable biofuels roundtable
roundtable on sustainable biofuels which
international standard for certification
so there is an opportunity for companies
to go and and follow this protocol
and
and the question is you know
that right now is a good model do we
need to continue to extend it and i
think absolutely we always we do need to
look at that so
just the focus on carbon is an important
piece but it can't be we would agree
that it can't be the only piece
here's one
that
that i think is
quite good
what do you think the
just an interesting hypothetical what do
you think the impact of carbon tax law
in the u.s would be on
china export
and also on to
you
uh american
economies and
way of life
so i'll start with you
so how big do you think that this would
have an impact if there was a carbon tax
in the u.s on china export and the
influence of that and then to you on the
economy
so i do think so if the u.s have a
common tax law so it will be affect some
uh exports from china so to the united
states so i think i so i
so and
so my perspective is that
i don't know when it could be happening
in the united states yeah so when the
the
when the u.s contacts the law could be
happened so if it's
if it's
two years one years of of course it will
be a very important impact
if it's it will be 10 years 20 years i
think that time china will be very
prepared so uh yeah yeah i mean i i
think that for the
right now i think it's
there's some impact so can you comment
just on the chance of a carbon tax in
china
yeah the carbon tax so we uh so right
now just imagine we have a we already
have a five uh six seven palace so in
five cities and in the two province
right now you see so in the beginning
for example so that know the carbon tax
the the the carbon press so in the chin
in beijing's cabinetry system and right
now it's ten dollars uh
ten dollars pretend it's much higher so
than at the beginning so and so
according to the the road map of china's
policy roadmap colombian policy roadmap
by the year 2020 so we will have a
national uh carbon uh cap and trade
system
so under that time time i did the
the carbon price could be as high as
20 dollars by the year 2020 is also
possible so
so one of the things i think is
interesting in this uh
climate change arena is how broad the
base of support for some kind of a price
and when we say carbon we really mean
carbon equivalent so all greenhouse gas
emissions and beyond um and i think the
the fact that you have uh policymakers
and economists from really across the
political spectrum agreeing that this is
the optimal policy pathway and yet
politically in the united states it's
proven to be extremely difficult uh
is worth pausing over and and thinking
about and and dr zhang is um you know
demonstrated that there are other places
that face a similar problem where this
is being moved forward and uh china is
doing
uh a number of things to put a price on
carbon that i think uh deserves study
and and we probably have something to
learn um in regard to how this plays out
i think that there will be a price in
one way or another on carbon over the
next decade at some point and i think it
will affect the flow of exports out of
china to the united states because at
least on the margin
it will make it more economical to
produce some things back in the united
states that are now being imported from
china and i think it's a fair point that
you would hate to see this done over a
year or two because it's jarring to the
economy but if it's implemented out over
a five or ten year period i think china
will adjust and china's own economy is
maturing it's increasingly producing for
a domestic marketplace and of course
there's great interest in the united
states in
insourcing in bringing back
manufacturing to the united states and
there are good reasons to think that's
going to happen anyway
as a result of the low cost particularly
natural gas that's increasingly
available for some sectors of the
economy so i think um the likely
economic impact is modestly to affect
exports from china the united states
modestly to increase production in the
united states and if done with the right
time frame doesn't have to be jarring to
anyone
thank you very much
i'll stick with the questions from the
audience for a bit this is to to karen
to you
will greater usage of electric fuel
vehicles
place more or less
stress on water consumption
where the electricity is being generated
from
so
in and of itself you know the electric
vehicle industry then just becomes
another user of electricity and you've
got to go back to source where you're
getting your electricity from
so ideally then you would say well
there's greater pressure on the
electricity sector so you want to try to
take the pressure off that again i think
uh you know it just provides another
reason to try to look at those energy
generation technologies that take the
pressure
better in terms of water land climate
risk vulnerability
so it to me it would just be another
reason to look carefully about your
energy generation mix
thank you um
you know we should think about electric
vehicles and how we do them
uh how we implement them
to be a strategy that can help promote
uh the types of generation solar wind
that don't have the same kind of water
impacts that other
central fossil fuel
infrastructure would and and it's
absolutely a great role for them in that
case
i wondered to the panel how because we
talked a little bit about it this
morning how
how can we reconcile
the both the challenges and the
opportunities created by local planning
regional planning national international
and and where again do you where do you
see the opportunities for that
and and what
what gets away in the way of the
implementation and dan maybe i'll start
i mean you've had direct experience with
this
how do you see this moving forward
so i think one of the interesting
developments over the last few years
in the united states but really around
the world is the growing action agenda
on climate change that's been cascaded
from
national governments to state and
provincial governments and perhaps even
now more to cities and i think this is a
very positive thing so i think
action on energy a push for clean energy
does require investments on the ground
it requires people actually do things
and i've actually long been worried
about
a
framework at the international level
that focuses entirely on setting targets
and timetables at a nation-state level i
think it would be much more interesting
if we had targets and timetables at the
state and provincial level at the city
level and frankly for corporations um
perhaps set by industry cluster
one of my experiences in my work in this
arena over now 20 years is that people
are best motivated by a structure that
has clear reporting on a common
methodology and allows for scorecarding
but not against all countries in the
world
for the national level but against
similarly situated nations and i think
likewise you could benchmark states and
provinces against each other similarly
situated and companies by industry
cluster and i think you could actually
get a lot done
by driving the action orientation the
investment decision making the planning
process
uh to those multiple levels and have
them in effect compete against each
other to see who can perform the best
that benchmarking score carding allows
you identify leaders and laggards
identify best practices and one of the
best strategies is simply to you know
extract best practices from a careful
analysis and then disseminate them more
broadly
thank you karen i saw you nodding to
that so i
last year i ran a project that was um
funded by i live in canberra which is in
the australian capital territory and
everyone thinks sydney is the capital
but it's not canberra is the capital
um it's a much nicer city and look me up
if you're over there
but we ran this project that was funded
by actual which is our local energy and
water utility combined it's it's a
unique company uh in australia for that
reason
and they came to us and they said um
they said look we're we're going to put
some money into a pilot project to do
smart metering energy storage at the
grid and the residential scale uh we're
basically everything that's new we're
going to pump into this pilot project
and we just want to see what happens um
and what they wanted us for was to
specifically look at the barriers uh or
impediments to the penetration of
distributed energy storage into their
aspect or their part of the national
electricity market
and it was a fascinating study because
it it
basically
every part of our regulatory
schema or landscape is designed to
support centralized energy supply and
there were very very good reasons for
that a lot of it was around security
supply or public health management and
maintenance of assets
but when you talk about distributed
renewable energy and distributed energy
storage
it totally changes the scale at which
energy is generated and used
and that means that you have to change
your uh the the laws have to change in
order to allow for these distributed
energy generators but for actual
purposes they were like how do we stay
viable as a centralized electricity
supplier
we pay for what the consumer pays but
ultimately through us we pay for the
pipes and the poles and the wires we pay
for the plants
and now you're saying that over the
coming decades we're going to have
little bits and pieces of assets at the
residential or the regional or the
suburban scale that we may not own
so how are we going to manage that
we may end up with stranded assets right
this is we the
electricity utility company we might
have all of these poles and pipes and
wires
that are not necessary in 20 years time
because
people in the act have really embraced
renewable energy and they will really
embrace energy storage
so for them it's about what is our
business going to be in 15 years
and therefore what do we need to be
lobbying for now to make that feasible
uh and it's it's quite fascinating
because it will you know it will it is
already seeing our regulatory
arrangements change um
can i just add a thought to that because
i think karen's actually said something
that represents one of the most
interesting areas uh where things are
going to be totally different over the
next 15 years where they are today and
that is
in the utility arena i think the
business model for these utilities all
over the world is going to be radically
shifted and the smart ones and it sounds
like you have one that you've been
working with are are thinking about this
and and and trying to get some on the
ground experience so that they can make
smart decisions about what the revenue
streams of the future would look like um
as a professor i can't help but give
everyone a homework assignment here
if you want to see what this is doing in
the united states look for
the ceo of our second biggest uh
fossil fuel utility nrg a guy named
david crane who three weeks ago wrote a
letter to shareholders which talks about
this revolution that's coming of
distributed generation household scale
power production and a need for his
business nrg in particular but the
utility industry more broadly to totally
transform over the course of the next
couple of decades and
i am awed by uh david crane's
willingness as a ceo in a very tough
conservative business and as a
representative a very traditional
utility to lay out uh a picture that
suggests
change is coming and you really have to
get your arms around it so it's a
three-page letter but absolutely
brilliant and i think gives you some
insight onto what the smart folks
looking at this are doing
and um dave to your question
it's actually really interesting where
you see the planning coming from the
utilities about what their world is
going to look like in the future
thanks very much for that i wonder if
there's
sure right
brian mars um works at nrg is here
and one of the things he said the
challenge of that model is that the
people
that are relying the most on the
standard electric utility grid in the
u.s are the less accurate
and we risk
as that model um
evolves
of leaving them behind do you have a
comment on that
i would only say um and we'll probably
get luke to talk about this too but
almost everything that moves the ball
forward
in terms of good policy frameworks to
address energy in the environment has a
regressive impact that is to say it's
easier for those who are relatively
affluent to address the change and to
invest in the new approach and
relatively burdensome to the poorer
segment of society so all of this policy
framework needs to have a separate track
that asks how do we ensure that we bring
along
the low-income segment of society and
we're going to need to have
special programs to ensure that this is
not going to have a severe regressive
impact on what is at least in this
country already a society that the
wealthy are doing very well and the
middle class are not doing so well and
the poor are doing very poorly so i
think it's a fair question and i would
just argue you don't not do these new
policies because they might be
regressive but you have to have a
separate track that addresses that
problem frontally
and i can give you an example from the
united kingdom i can't remember the
financial house that did it but they've
established interest-free loans for um
you know in the uk they have commission
housing flats
so interest-free loans for for those
commission council council-run housing
flats to
buy and install solar pv panels
at that scale
which then allows them to
generate their own electricity and
bypass the electricity pricing from your
centralized electricity supply
and if they generate more than that
obviously then they become a seller and
it was specifically designed to address
the lower socio-economic strata of
society so there are people thinking
about how this can be can be combated
and interesting in the uk case it came
from a bank essentially
and i'll just quickly add that we are
we're part of an effort in california
um
where we partnered with some
environmental justice groups um
and other groups representing lower
income folks out there you know when you
think about um
people of
that are um
lower income people the their
transportation costs are probably a much
bigger percentage of their overall
income
versus uh the more affluent folks so
actually for an electric vehicle for
them makes more sense than anybody else
right because the per mile costs are so
low so it really is this question of how
do you get over that up front piece and
so we're partnering with some of these
groups to
in this case ensure that there's
long-term funding out of the california
cap and trade system that that
specifically addresses some of these
issues
thank you thanks luke are there is there
another question out in the audience
working yeah you got it on
a question about energy economics
generally
energy costs are rising and we need
cheaper energy
for decades and and
going off a little bit here to folks for
explanation for decades the us dollar
has acted as the world's reserve
currency
but in an effort to reduce trading costs
including for energy trading
it's been reported that china has begun
direct currency trading with
several countries in the past two years
this includes
australia
which commenced direct currency trading
in april 2013 one year ago
so my question
specifically for
china and australia
if you could speak to it have you seen
reductions in energy costs because of
this
and i realize this is this might be a
little off topic but i thought i would
ask because you're here
see trading but energy costs have gone
up in recent years uh well electricity
costs have gone up in recent years and
that's because we spent the last 10
years building
you know more plants and more
poles and wires right so we're now
we're now paying for the capital
expenditure that that
was expanded in the last decade i've got
no idea how that relates to currency
trading
but i'm looking forward to hearing
zhang's answer
my observation i don't because of the
right now also the
the this part the the amount is very is
relatively small so and i don't think it
has a very important impact on tennis
the energy codes and the press right now
thank you another question from the art
please
zhang this is a follow up on your smog
comment
so for the people in china and for the
government
what is the greatest driver of future
energy change is it climate change or is
it in fact the public health concerns
related to the detrimental air quality
okay so i think in the context channel
so and we have a lot of challenges the
most of the challenge is
i think is we because we need to
development so under the the economic
growth that the increased energy
needs is very high how to
how to meet this is a very important
issue because the decreased energy is
very high so we
in the world in china and also in world
no cheap
energy resources available so that's why
we have channels have very important
motivation to promote the energy to
increase energy efficiency to promote
energy contribution i think it's a very
important motivation another of course
it's a local air quality so
the
the people
so it's
dangerous the environment so and people
right
most recently completed a lot so i think
it's very important or another
and also climate change so and because
climate change policy also have a
significant medical benefits so this is
also very much in line is the chinese
domestic interest that's why china
the the economic policy and the policy
so can be uh
promote have been implemented um
much easily so in in the context of
china okay
thank you i'd like to just ask a
question because we haven't talked that
much about it which is probably the
biggest change in the
world energy
has been the advent of unconventional
natural gas this was driven largely by
the private sector and infusions of
large amounts of capital
from your standpoint then in
connecticut i mean you really helped
move this forward in a way that would be
advantageous to the state
i'm interested in how you see that going
in the future do you see it playing an
ever-increasing role or or a lesser role
and then i'm i'm very interested
in china from the standpoint of how do
you see gas economically
competing with coal
as we look forward in the next five
because that's going to be such a
crux aspect
and then finally luke maybe you can talk
about the use of natural gas this is a
question that we have in in vehicles and
and how that might play a role so dan
you've had the immediate uh perspective
on this maybe you can comment on that so
as i said earlier i think one of the
keys to success
in moving towards a clean energy future
is to have that clean energy future be
not just clean but cheap and reliable
and i think the push to
expand natural gas in connecticut was in
the spirit of the best option for
cheaper cleaner and more reliable at
least over the next decade or two
but i continue to see natural gas as
really a bridge to a cleaner energy
future and i think this is why i've
tried to emphasize and i think
you agreed and i think a lot of us
believe that a portfolio approach is the
right thing and that we want to have our
best fossil fuel option uh be at the
forefront over the next couple of
decades but not take the push
off for an even cleaner future beyond
that with a real ramp up of renewables
and one of the things i guess i haven't
said that i should have emphasized
earlier
is the key i think from the government
policy point of view is to try to drive
deployment
of clean energy at scale because that's
how you really will bring down cost as
well as driving further innovation and
breakthroughs and so i do see natural
gas playing a major role a growing role
in the united states and elsewhere out
over the next couple of decades but then
peaking and tailing somewhere out over
the 20 30 year time frame thank you
thank you
coal and natural gas
and also just drive by the local air
quality issues uh the smokes and now
china so and the the
the use of natural gas has been
increased significantly so before we're
talking about on the yield the future
portable use of natural gas in china so
it's about
the the use in the host holes for the
for the cooking and for the cooking and
also for some uh
material of the industry so chemical
industry we never think about for poor
generation for space heating but right
now so i think a very
important change and so the network is
there are more uh
opportunities
used so in the power generation and also
in space heating so and according to the
recent regulation you begin no coffer
power plants could be built if you want
to invest in beijing for pronunciation
you only can use uh natural gas
potential
power plants can even navigate natural
gas propellants and also
within the the the fourth ring of
beijing for space heating
before is a cold boiler
but right now you have to shut down and
replace the by natural gas i think
that's why they traded
the use of net gas has been increased
significantly amount so and this is
residue but
most of this use the best uh pollination
and the space heating is heavily
subsidized by the government and all and
only the rich government like beijing so
if the government they have money you
can substitute but for other cities
maybe the story is difficult so i think
this is the
the this is the trends and i'm right now
the most competitive use of natural gas
so maybe it's used for the
trucks heavy duty trucks and the
taxis and the buses so in
in the in the cities so
so this is the the situation i think
everything
that the cost so it's a very important
limitation so for the to actually
utilize the solution of the natural gas
thank you
luke maybe you can address the heavy
duty vehicle
yes certainly i think that um when we
talk about expansion of natural gas i
think we we do need to recognize that
there are questions
um and a lot of research going around
what the current extraction technologies
are and what's the impact uh from a
total greenhouse gas life cycle
perspective of using natural gas with
the way that we're extracting it you
know primarily methane leakage and we
that's a i think that that's a problem
that we can cost effectively deal with
but we need to deal with it because
you know natural gas has a lower
um
you know lower carbon content than coal
uh
but we want to make sure that we
actually
achieve that lower carbon content and
when it comes to vehicles we see natural
gas especially in the light d light duty
vehicle sector
uh a more effective use of it is to put
it into a power plant
and then to
that's displacing a coal power plant and
then power electric vehicle for it
because the electric vehicle
is is so efficient that you're going to
get a better environmental
footprint
through that use of natural gas as
opposed to directly putting it into an
internal combustion engine
and i think the other thing we have to
think about is where do we need to be
from a long-term perspective
in our vehicle fleet well we need to get
to electric drive so
again that should be uh where our focus
is now in the heavy duty sector the use
of electricity to drive heavy-duty
vehicles is
it's got more challenges in terms of uh
just the energy that's required the
density of that energy that's required
and so natural gas is actually you know
starting to see
a resurgence of use within heavy-duty
vehicles and and i think that that's
likely to be uh a growing market
although i think overall natural gas
within the transportation sector will
continue to be a pretty small slice
we're going to take about five more
minutes of question some of our
panelists have some uh commitments and
we've had a good discussion so knowing
that there's only five more minutes and
knowing that you don't want to walk out
of here saying i wish i'd asked that
question are there any any burning
questions
there is one good
thank you see how burning it is um i
have a question for professor john
we know that as china really is wanting
to clean up the air
we also see a lot of
new gasification gasification plants and
moving power plants away from the urban
centers therefore increasing carbon
intensity and
transmission loss
so i'm wondering you know both for
short-term and long-term
how much of the co-benefits you see we
can actually claim
thank you
so and uh
yeah
so so the
so there is a this is because these are
burning questions because there is a
well there is a lot of debates and uh
the arguments in china about the co
gratification to for
the co-education for uh for for natural
gas so the co-2 cultural gas so and
so there's uh
i think in the uh so there's a
moment to to the mainly the moment all
mainly from the the coal industry and of
course it's also associated with the the
air quality air
clean clean cleaning so but i think
there is another the voice is to
make the the policy china policy very in
the future be because be cautious so
it's also involved a lot of uh the rules
issues and also the annual infinity
issues and from the life cycle analysis
perspective so it is
code to leak to gas and be used so the
efficiency there was a significant
penalty and also the the the co2
emission so
it's a very big issue with king since
but there were some recently so there
are government there are some
discussion i think another target for
the go-to uh guest is is very cautious
it's a i don't think it should be a very
very big uh
amount of code liquids will go to gas
could be
happens in china okay
thank you very much
the utility structures of the us china
australia other other areas
how do they compare in the ease of
adapting distributed generating
generation technologies
what will what do you see as is it
easier someplace less easy why and how
would it vary in the different regions
that we've talked about what what could
help make this breakthrough
uh so i think it depends a lot on how
invested people are in an existing
infrastructure that they're going to
have to write off which is i think what
we heard as well from australia and
frankly i think
the the two critical questions here are
one are there policy incentives put in
place that help this transition and two
and maybe even more important is there
leadership within that utility sector
business leadership that helps us get
towards the future you've described
so in a context china so
as we know so we have a two uh very uh
what is the two very big uh only big two
big great companies one is the national
state grid company and on the south
china
green company the only two green company
so particularly the the state group
companies they are they are big monopoly
so in the
transformation and distribution
so i think unfortunately a very
important barrier is the institutional
barrier so for the use of the
distributed system the the the in the
past kind of push a lot for the
diffusion the use of the distribution
but the
the progress is very limited uh
right now is a good news it seems that
so the the the the
uh
the situation is getting better so under
the pressures of the society the whole
society and also there is a lot of
discussion about how to reform the
chinese uh the electricity system so i
think maybe more and more more uh
regulations will be most basically
specifically tolerant
tolerant for the to the to the to the
use of the uh
the distributed system particularly the
solar pv system in the cities so it
seems it's a it seems we have to do this
yeah
thank you very much
now i know we haven't been able to get
to all the questions we tried to get
through uh most of them and i hope
you've enjoyed the discussion and
learned as much as i have from the
discussion i'd like to thank each of our
panelists
for
the quality of your discussion and that
the material that you brought here
for your travels and for sharing it with
us and it's been a real pleasure so
thank you very much
you